[Music]
building interoperability across systems
and healthcare poses unique challenges
especially if they are siloed this is
where the healthcare api
helps accelerate the uploading sending
analyzing storing and interfacing with
other healthcare data via cloud-based
applications
and so in this episode we will talk
about what is the healthcare api and
what are some best practices around
using fire
api stands for application programming
interface
and is a kind of library of functions
that passes information over the web
it defines the inputs and outputs
available over http
the healthcare api specifically bundles
multiple tools and processes
that help application developers deliver
compliance in a heavily regulated
environment
as well as store sensitive patient
information in a more convenient and
standard manner
and even though you enable it like you
do with any other api
in the google cloud console the
healthcare api contains
specialized data storing modalities in
order to support
dicom hl7 v2 and fire
daikon means digital imaging and
communications in medicine
and we will talk more about that in
another episode
next is hl7v2 which is an event
messaging service that was created in
1989 for healthcare entities to
communicate with each other
such as medical providers labs insurers
etc now there are two common challenges
however
the first is that it's semi-structured
data and that is difficult to parse
and the second is that it uses a
protocol that predates the internet's
http
standard to overcome these the
healthcare api can store the messages in
its raw format or parse the messages
for developers to more easily work with
it
and one can overcome the protocol's web
constraints by also using
a free adapter in tandem with the
healthcare api
doing this also then expands your
ability to leverage additional cloud
infrastructure tools
which can help process massive amounts
of data to find
insights or apply machine learning next
moving on to fire which stands for fast
healthcare interoperability resources
this is an api and data standard that
came about as the industry has been
working on improving the exchange of
electronic health records by leveraging
modern web-based technologies like oauth
json
and html the healthcare api has the
benefit of mapping data
as a graph or a web of resources that
are interconnected
and you can perform human queries over
them
let's take a quick look on top of a
robust set
of api functionalities the healthcare
team has built a user interface
to interact with google cloud's
healthcare api
here i am looking at the data set view a
way for
organizations to logically partition
their resources
if i click in i have the ability to
create data stores
right within the interface data stores
can include consent
dicom hl7 and fire
when creating a firestore i can attach a
cloud
pub subtopic for triggering downstream
workflows
this will essentially fire off when
there are any changes made to the
backend database
i can also attach a label for use cases
like billing
and choose which version of fire i would
like to utilize
back in the data set view i have the
ability to import
export to both google cloud storage and
bigquery de-identify my data
delete or open up into a fire viewer
this fire viewer is a interface to be
able to see the data and interact with
the data
without directly invoking the backend
api
we can see our resources are listed and
i'll be searching for the encounter
resource
this is listing all of the encounters i
have
within my firestore if i click in
we can see there's an overview elements
and json tab the elements is a logical
representation
of the raw json object we still have the
ability to view it as a json object
if your developers would prefer within
elements
each of these is a drop down so for
example
when looking at reason code we can see
there's a snomed code associated with
this encounter
we also have the ability to check things
like referential integrity
which is the ability to refer to another
resource in the
firestore this is currently telling me
this practitioner was the owner
or who saw the person within this
encounter
we can click the practitioner and
actually go view their data
in the data set so not only do we have a
robust set
of implementations within the fire api
we also have a developer friendly tools
to better leverage the product
fire's been getting a lot of buzz in the
market today due to its promise in
interoperability
and u.s legislation changes one of the
main benefits that we see in
organizations that move towards a
fire-based data model
is the ability to unlock real-time use
cases
google's fire server is built on the
same technology
that cloud spanner is built on and run
on thus
this allows for high transactions and
throughput
both necessary things for ai and
analytics use cases
one of the biggest considerations an
organization should make
when adopting a firebase standard is how
well it scales
ideally a fire service should be able to
hold
all an organization's data without a
large loss in performance
that's one of the best things about
managed products and google cloud's fire
api
it will automatically scale to meet your
workload and your data storage needs
that way an organization can use it for
any number of use cases
without having a need for data
replication or bringing latency into
their applications
to learn more visit cloud.google.com
forward slash healthcare
and to get started you will need to have
a google cloud project
if you do not have one i have included a
link to a trial account with free
credits in this video's description
along with other helpful resources and
community if you found this episode
helpful
you can subscribe to the channel to get
notifications of
more healthcare episodes cheers
[Music]
you